so I would always be an inch wire in a
mile deep so pick a niche two or three
job titles and one area and stick to it
you'll thank yourself kind of six eight
months down the line because you'll be
able to get one candidate and send it
out to four or five places so definitely
definitely definitely do that I'm
massive on Market mapping you spend two
weeks just banging candidates and
getting manager names leads and getting
them on New Market map that is you
Goldust that's live data data is just
data do not neglect the data I would
I'll do it with somebody because it's
very very lonely we've had stock days
yeah yeah yeah there's been days where
everything's gone wrong and just a phone
call to each other you feel ten times
better I'll just come off it so pick
your partner
make sure you can be completely honest
that person if it's you just need
unfiltered honesty
and don't look at your data the
recruitment mentors podcast is proudly
sponsored by VIN cherry and the
award-winning Source breaker